we're finishing up the symposium and
we've got two more speeches to go
there's a little bit of you know back
and forth dialogue that's kind of
interesting in there at the end of the
symposium this particular good well the
last will hint about what's going on so
we'll see if we can get to that but this
is the main stuff Socrates is talking
for quite a while and this is really the
core symposium the thing that most
people remember about the symposium 20
years later is Aristophanes speech and
you know people in half and your seem to
be searching for your missing you know
lost self and all that sort of but
Socrates speech is the one where you
really get the most important material
and then it looks like things have come
to a close and what happens this guy
Agathon shows up drunk with a little
bunch of friends comes in Boston to the
party and you know all sorts of
interesting stuff and Sue's and then he
gets a speech a typical Agathon everyone
has to make exceptions for him don't we
do a speech exactly on the topic that
who else was and he says I'm not going
to give you a really good speech I'm
just kind of jumping things up because
I'm drunk
I'm gonna talk about Socrates instead
and it is connected with love why
because the Agathon what he's in love
with Socrates man so much so that
Socrates who's Athena old guy and the
tough guy has to tell Agathon you got to
get in between the two of us because
Agathon you know he's always trying to
get get after me so it's kind of a funny
thing you know a lot of funny images of
us and well we'll get to that
the big stuff so Socrates won't give a
regular speech and this is pretty
typical Socrates one of the things that
here's here's a term that we use a lot
when we're talking about Socrates and I
think it has a bit of a different
meaning these days when something is
ironic or a person is being ironic what
it what does that mean - usually
we don't really talk about people being
ironic right yeah situations or things
that people say and there's usually like
some sort of bitterness to it like look
at that
the guy who committed all these crimes
stealing cars his own car got stolen
isn't that ironic that's a different
sense of irony than what Plato is
talking about or or or Socrates does
with Socrates he'll think of irony as
having like two layers there is the
lower layer of you know don't really
know or you don't say no really why
don't you tell me all about it you seem
so smart give me your opinion I'm not
the entire time Socrates really has
something
so I mean um for example Socrates says
I'm not a good speaker I'm just gonna
have to like it out the way it
ordinarily do yes I use a good speaker
yeah he's a great speaker particularly
when he can bring somebody else into the
dialogue and then recite their words or
perhaps make them up on the spot we
don't know existed or not and give up an
entire speech he's able to replicate
this this sorta stuff is the stuff that
Socrates is saying coherent does it hang
together as as a speech that's part of
speech writing right and public speaking
is being able to talk without seeming
like you're just rambling around did
Socrates as discussion seem just
rambling around no point to them or was
there a point to them he does know what
he's doing he kind of pretends like he
doesn't irony is a pretending to be less
capable and knowledgeable than you
actually are so as to get people off
their guard and this is actually you
know a good thing to do in a lot of
contexts I highly recommend it to you
because people will say all sorts of
things when they think that you're
actually not that bright reveal things
to you that they wouldn't ordinarily
reveal I don't know for example we can
talk about irony in terms of dress I
don't dress like this in most contexts
you know if I'm going out to a nice
dinner party yes if I'm teaching yes but
most of the time I'm more of a jeans and
flannel kind of guy and I don't look
like a sort of typical academic and
listen to what people say and when
people are left or are dumb they'll say
a lot of really interesting things
well they thank you guys
so Socrates does that and he gets us is
you know fellow interlocutors lot start
quite often and then now is he doing it
just to be a jerk to show how clever he
is might seem that way sometimes but
really he's trying to teach he's trying
to bring out something from his fellow
speakers and he's going to do this with
the Agathon might seem like kind of bad
manners
it's Agathon's house right Agathon is
the host of the party you just want a
contest you just gave a great speech
what did Socrates do immediately after
that ask you a few questions and one of
those questions reveal to us about
ex-con in his speech yeah yeah
he doesn't know anything he was praising
love and he was saying love has this
this quality remember love is beautiful
totally beautiful love is totally good
and then he just like opens up the
floodgates of rhetoric yeah and like
psychic she says you like gave us a bath
pour it over our poured it over our
heads
where's the big flaw in Agathon's views
about this so active is able to get
about one little point you might not
require because he spent so much time
like going through particular examples
but what is this point what he's talking
let's just start with two towards love
beauty they just love usually the act
I'm saying mom is yeah let me say
something like desiring what if it's the
other way around
did you ever you didn't so percent of
love is not beauty
love is not beauty because love let's
look that's going to be the conclusion
because love desires so there is a
desire in there but it's flipped around
now if I have desire or something why do
I desire it generally yeah already have
it exactly so if you decide for one who
know everything you really like this
truck you desire it until you actually
have it then of course once you have it
you desire to keep it yeah but so long
as I've got this piece of Chagas you
know you have to just decide you're
hungrily think about all the things you
could write on the board so love desires
beauty so lovely is not beauty love
laughs
and the same thing for the good love
loves the good love his love of the good
and so love is not good Agathon was
completely wrong he was he was saying
love is like the best of these things
its beauty itself its goodness itself
instead of love is actually steering us
towards those things now if that's the
case if love is not good
love must be evil done right where love
is and that beauty love must be ugly and
that's where Agathon more or less ly as
a lock Socrates says well let me tell
you this story about this lady that I
needed a long time ago her name was do
de ma she was a you know some sort of
religious leader you know priestess
prophetess here she was able to you know
keep the plague from happening in Athens
for for over a decade you know if he
goes down like a list of her she is the
philosopher of love he goes to her for
love lessons that sounds you know a
little bit like he's you know a young
guy going to you know brothel you know
learn about sexual techniques or
something like that it's nothing like
that this is more along the lines where
we talked about with tonic love he wants
to spend time with her so that he can
acquire wisdom so he can acquire
knowledge so he can become a better
person and she knows about this for this
stuff so she says well you're making a
really mistaken assumption you know you
have good and bad of these not good or
the automatically bad or somebody is
neither here you know
they're not fair beautiful are they
necessarily ugly what's your experience
if you're not getting an A in this class
are you necessarily getting enough why
not
yeah there's BC and D right
Paris has some kind of weird thing I
hate losses
I think they don't have d-minuses not
sure exactly why but a C would be like
right in between three would be what we
call mean for middle between one extreme
and another extreme right some things
are definitely good some things are
definitely bad some things are that you
know or sometimes good sometimes bad
good in certain respects bad in other
respects think about beauty and and
ugliness have any of you liked seeing
these things on websites were they they
show famous actors and models with you
know they're in there sort of gone
through their native habitat their
environment on velocity magazine pages
and then they show them without the
photoshopping without the makeup what
else Photoshop you make people do a lot
maybe out with their kids or something
like that big difference right now you
know some people are still pretty
good-looking even after you take all the
makeup off some of them are right
you're like wow that's some that makeup
artist deserves a million bucks a year
because they turn that that person who
was waiting over here
and something over here wonder how they
even thought to apply it to them I mean
they could have applied it to anybody
and probably resolved but there's quite
a few people who are just sort of
in-between right and then what light
you're looking at them in their have the
experience of being attracted to
somebody and you know just physically
attracted you like the way they look and
then what are they they're doing some
some different light you're like what's
wrong with their babies I don't like
their hair actually you think I like
their hair I thought that was one of the
best things about them but it's kinda
scraggly yeah pick whatever you like
that would be in between they're not you
don't like stop a clock ugly but they're
not beautiful either and we can talk
this way about a lot of different things
and do demand I actually does bring up a
lot of different examples so what are
some of the other things that she she
brings up as these these extremes
that service
yeah mortal or beyond mortal where women
law doesn't either once
love isn't immortal because love can die
but love comes back to life as human
beings at Plato's got a whole different
account I can say afterlife no we don't
go into that human beings you know when
the body dies that that body's done it
doesn't come back to life you're gonna
say stuff like well you know it feeds
the fishes or grass grows out of it but
that's not that body coming to life
that's other things growing on it what
else
so the divinity is an important
attribute is lot of lies no I mean even
if we put plate on the side and you've
been in love would you call your feeling
of love particularly otherwise about
things maybe in a lot of cases no leads
that are just crazy stuff what was not
entirely ignorant either the ignorance
the way Plato understands this are not
only lacking in knowledge but they're ok
with them they're fine of them they're
happy with that there's a called self
satisfied with their condition
the philosopher the literally wisdom
lumber they want what they don't have
but they can at least recognize that
they don't have it this is kind of an
important point that that doesn't get
stretched a lot here but does get
stressing on your Platonic dialogues
being conscious of your own lack of
wisdom your own ignorance on certain
topics is already in advance beyond
ignorance it's not yet - no but it's to
know that there's something more for you
to know and it also makes you look a
little bit more humble right you're less
likely to say I know all about that
ignorant people quit often don't even
know they're ignorant
that's what ignorant they are this is
Kayla that aggression but it's it's a
great example for this sort of thing
they did a study and then some years ago
I was British people who disagree
remember right yeah and they were
looking at a lot of different ranges of
qualities of people you know that we
divide things up by what they call four
tiles so like you know 75 100 percent 75
down to 50 and we can do this like test
scores like all of you are probably the
top quartile pretty selective school you
can do this with other things too like
physical attractiveness ability to get
worked on you know all sorts of things
what was really interesting was the fact
that people in the top quartile
generally know that they're at the top
of their game people in the middle two
quartiles generally have a fairly decent
idea about where they fit in they asked
people to rate themselves what do you
think about people in the Bob really the
results were just guessing yeah probably
exactly yeah not only do they not
realize they're in the bottom quartile
they don't place themselves in like the
next highest quartile or even the next
they think that they're at the time so
people who are particular
stupid will often think that they're
really brilliant that you know that's
exactly what Socrates is talking about
here ignorant people are not just like
you know people who are like saying yeah
I don't really know anything I have to
admit it to you those are the people who
are actually in the middle the people
who are convinced that they actually
have knowledge they're the ones who are
in there so love is this in-between day
and she's got this great discussion of
love as being the intermediary between
the gods and he's a dime own and in
between sort of communicative
interpretive spirit this is a you know
common belief for the Greeks out there
were these these in-between kind of
things if you wanted to get something
done you know necessarily have gone
directly you don't or the gods it she's
got the story as well about his birth
which I'm going to skip over it's kind
of a nice comic story about it
essentially what we call it I mean they
wouldn't call it a date rape because
they're not actually like out of date
together
you got this guy who's passed out this
woman who says I want to have a kid by
him so I actually have something and had
sex with him manages to get him get out
in the game so to speak and brings to
Bertha a child namely love who's who's
the in-between because she's over here
she is poverty she never has anything
and her his day out is plenty so love is
in between poverty and plankton there's
always something in my stuff coming out
he lacks resources but he can always
find resources there's this whole
beautiful description in there
but then we start extending this to
other people love is not the only
philosopher Socrates says who died
autumn are the lovers of wisdom if
they're neither the wise are the foolish
just as well love is one of them wisdom
is a multiple to any love is of the
beautiful love is a philosopher of over
with them and those who do philosophy
and philosophy can be very broad here
you can think of what you're doing in
your major it's doing something like
philosophy you're trying to acquire
knowledge you're trying to acquire
wisdom that places you in this category
here you can't learn until you actually
realize what you you don't know now she
shifts gears she's going to start
talking about the mysteries of love
which is unveiling through these lesser
and then greater mysteries we come again
to this question
loved one what does the lover one we've
all felt love right at least you know
the form of sexual attraction or
excitement about something admiration
friendship the questions what are we
actually driving after what is what is
moving us you know Aristophanes setting
was to be reunited with our right
somebody liked it Eric semi kiss would
say well you know it's for things to be
in alignment and healthy the elements
the elements of something different and
she does this Socratic question with him
leading him through through a dialectic
she says somebody might say of the
beautiful and what love is of the
beautiful question is what so what a
beautiful things that we feel love
towards hesitate
are those a sort of crime thing that we
tend to feel long to it's beautiful or
handsome there are traffic
yeah are there other people weird you
know they look at other people and I'm
like person was really attractive so I'm
gonna flip through a magazine traction
or something like that
are there other things that we we love
because it's beautiful
maybe we don't use the word love we use
other and good because they're warm and
cuddly and they are cute when they do
this or that but anybody I mean there
are certainly animals where we look at
the Baja horse is amazing look at its
grace you know there are hardened
gamblers who like throwing it I'll slit
your throat and throw right there life's
amounts of wife savings they might do
that their life savings the way out of
horse race who can nevertheless at the
same time appreciate the grace are
running horses something that the
humanity has been fascinated with for
watching you know big cats at play we're
hunting there's really something to that
going some people like to go hunting by
the way not just you know to shoot it
here but to watch the deer to watch them
walk there's a certain grace to that
there are the natural things to you like
you might you know like a particular
part we're surrounded by natural beauty
here and lots of valley you know there's
a walk down to the boathouse look at the
Hudson River and that could be an object
of love for you something of beauty you
know some people do go down there
frequently
music can strike us that way there are
certain musical pieces that were not
able to say exactly what it is that we
love about them but we do love them
right there may be certain movies
certain poems certain other types of
works captain but then again you might
love your car because you love them the
lines and the design of your car yeah so
in it all sorts of things so she asked
well when a person who loves the
beautiful what is it that they really
desire we want possession and here they
come to to kind of a halt she says what
do you get out of that when you possess
some some article of beauty so let's
take something really easy to relate to
I'm willing to bet that for every one of
you I asked you about your mp3
collections there's some song in your
mp3 collections that you if you had to
like only pick one song that you could
keep an image difficult and there's two
or three or ten but if there is only if
there if I said you can only keep one
song I'm going to delete your entire
collection and you'll never be a little
upload another song again which one
would you pick you pick a song it's not
going well I've got the storage space
I'll put it on there it's one that you
feel really connected to you possess
that right you you probably listen to it
and willing to that at least once a week
yeah sometimes it moves you and
sometimes it doesn't
what is it that you actually are getting
out of that socrates isn't able to say
are we able to put our finger around
there yeah feels good yeah this yeah
maybe maybe it's a way of you know some
people think that art is a way of
dealing with the pain of life you know
it brings us up okay maybe there's
something to that guy named Schopenhauer
yeah much much later than Plato Socrates
isn't able to figure out what we
actually want on having the beautiful a
lot of them's we don't know I mean we're
attracted to somebody we date them we
get into a relationship with them why
did I get into this now that we change
it to dance a little bit more manageable
why do people want good things as
opposed to just beautiful things well
what is it that they want they want
possession I'll be good
those who possess the good what do they
actually gain up the good thing that
they want what else what are they really
driving it
and you know we think about the
beautiful that's what we want to we
think the beautiful is going to make us
happy a beautiful object that we yeah
that's why we're often so disappointed
right because we we get something and it
is beautiful mineral life of to think of
the beautiful course you know the source
is so so wonderful but now I got to feed
the thing clean the stables do all this
whatever word hurt the horse is sick and
it's got to go to the back man this
thing is hard to ride it's try to bite
may or may may or may not go well but
we're actually driving after happiness
this is our our fundamental goal in life
and if you ask further well what does
somebody want to get out of being happy
that's one of those points where you can
give somebody legitimately as a
philosopher the blank stare and say what
do you mean wait wait you know you don't
want to be happy because you know even
the people who just want to be miserable
and [ __ ] and whine all the time they
want to be happy that's just what
happiness consists in for them I think
you know it's so cool right they're
never happy unless they're humming happy
they still want to be happy we all want
happiness and it you know takes on
different shapes and we imagine it in
different ways but this is something
that drives all of us according to Plato
and according to many other philosophers
so we're maybe happy by acquiring good
things and how long are we going to be
happy so long as we have these good
things so how long do we want to keep
the good things forever
exactly eternal so you know this goes a
long way to explaining why we are
oftentimes in the midst of such funny
not very happy people you know a lot of
the things that we have are not designed
to last we live in a throwaway society
if Plato is right then having a few nice
things that you can keep for a long time
you know for example I have this dossier
I've had this dossier juror quite awhile
and my wife was the one who was
instrumental in me getting it and latha
she you know talked us into spending the
money on it because it wasn't cheap so
it's a coach one even buying in an
outlet it was it was pricey this is
great compared to the other Nazi aids
that I've had that had fallen apart I am
tough on equipment I break things I'm
not careful you know it's kind of
scuffed this will probably last me you
know a good portion of the rest of my
career and it fits nice looks nice and
like the wind feels the other things
that I bought the pasture I said well
for half the price I could get you know
this one I wasn't as happy with them it
didn't make me as happy it wasn't just
you know the the duration it was the
quality we want things that will make us
happy forever we seek
eternal happiness eternal possession of
the good now here there's a digression
that I want to spend a little time of
time on because it is important when you
use these terms like love and love and
poetry yeah we can talk about words in
broad senses of the term and very narrow
specific senses of the time so for
example let's take clothing all right
you wouldn't call that necessarily a
shirt per se but like a blouse right or
a what you're wearing
yeah oh no you're wearing a dress yeah I
couldn't see under the desk I mean it is
a blouse a kind of shirt in a broad
sense right but when you say shirt you
generally mean something more like this
what makes it a blouse well just the
fact of a woman where is it I'm not a
fashion person we also talked about you
know t-shirts possibly is button-down
shirts that's more specific right they
all fall into the category of shirt but
you might pick some were described
things more more carefully now what
about love and lover when we think of
love we tend to think of a few things so
we talked about the innocent friendship
romantic love and attraction love that
program and siblings share that sort of
thing might extensive like love whoa
country or I love this food I love this
song we're the lovers when we call
somebody a lover
what what are we talking about yeah
where did you raise me in there yeah
right here
person you're interested in like that
you know
yeah and it's usually romantic rival
physical nature yeah I don't I don't
call I'm not
for instance a we wouldn't call me a
lover of my friend over there right or
we don't call me a lover of my mom it's
funny too because my my adopted mom
drove me nuts you know I couldn't
picture anybody do something like like
like that to be involved but you know
some people do what else do we talk
about we're so we have we have lovers in
the romantic sense we call somebody a
lover
they give me a wine lover right
chocolate lover car lover who say horse
lover and all that sounds a little
ambiguous kind of get worried maybe
that's kind of dirty right
what about poet nature into contemporary
poets that come to mind who's your
favorite color
I'd drown oh yeah not exactly
contemporary got to reach passionate
that's like that almost two centuries
right we don't I mean we do have poets
these days right where you wanted to
find poets where should you probably go
yeah regardless ah yeah we do our poetry
through through lyrics poetry and the
rhyming sense rap and hip-hop are
probably the closest to an ancient Greek
poetry because the ancient Greek poetry
was not only about and the ride it was
about meter so if you have a rhythm
where it's going and that's part of the
words that's like ancient Greek Atlanta
poetry like for example aristocracy had
frog sang bracket kick xbox Cox Beca
connects coax coax alumni first but
that's from this that's ancient Greek
from his has played the frogs it was in
poetry and they had that rhythm to it
that done the Odyssey is written in
meter as a matter of fact a lot of the
old biblical stuff is written in meter
as well the Greek set up had even
broader conception of poetry so it
included what we call plays it would
include what we include as music history
was not poetry but in a broader sense
everything that's creative is poetry
everything which is bringing something
from non-being a state of not existing
to existing is poetry so how many are
any of you athletes if you have it what
about sports doing this play
what's up Rick Carelli Chris rowing crew
okay what else
rowing crew yeah track okay where is it
must be cross-country this season right
okay rugby okay any other sports every
time that you guys are engaged in
athletic competitions you're creating
something you're creating a performance
rowing requires and actually I mean is
that something you can even sort of do
your own thing like your bro how would
that work out you wouldn't live on your
teammates it'd be infuriating right
everyone has to work together there's
something about being on a team when
everything actually comes together
we're like when you're running and you
get that groove you know and moving
ahead
you know what feels like you're in slow
motion you can like see the other people
sort of receding into the background
there's a lot very aesthetic about that
when you you may not think of it this
way when you mow the lawn how many of
you have ever like cut grass more than
once in your life now how did it feel
other than being tired maybe ticked off
the after you mowed the whole lawn and I
went from being the shabby scraggly
unkempt can't thank to being a very
neatly groomed green was there any
pleasure in them you created something
we're all creative we're all poets we're
all lovers according to the only one
it's just a question of what we actually
create or love and the broad sense all
of us are are tied into this and all of
humanity so she says
going back to the good we want to have
the everlasting possession of the good
how do we do this well this is where the
poetry and the lover stuff comes in we
as she says bring to earth so you have a
blogger and then you have some sort of
let's call it a medium okay and the
medium itself has to be in some way
beautiful the lover has desire and the
hand desire to create something in the
medium to bring to birth in the metaphor
that she has we're all pregnant we're
all pregnant either in our bodies or our
souls and it you know it's kind of a
weird way of thinking about so it
doesn't match to what we what you learn
in health class but sexual reproduction
the way it works I mean we know now that
you actually need you know chromosomes
are both parents and the egg contributes
the sperm contributes something put all
that side just just right and imagine
this what is it that we're actually
trying to do when we're creating things
we're trying to bring something to birth
in a beautiful medium or at least a
potentially beautiful think about food
and cooking for example how many of you
ever worked at restaurants
so you know that there's a lot of things
you probably don't want to see going on
behind the scenes and restaurants that
drive with your experience and sometimes
the uncooked food stuff someone's very
attractive some of its really ugly you
know but when it's cooked and it's
plated and you produce something you may
have taken a medium that was not by
itself beautiful and you've created
something beautiful food by the way is
is a object of art to be consumed that
way you can tell that it's really great
as nothing's left unusual because music
we want to have that for recording but
we all want to create so the question is
what kind of things do we create we're
trying to create so as to have something
that is going to be eternal left behind
so when that she uses just man here we
need to think about this in terms of
women and the traction from that as well
when human beings are attracted to each
other and I have sex with each other
what are they trying to do have a good
time maybe you can express their love
for each other but what they're really
trying to do is make babies
the reason why they're trying to make
babies is to leave something behind to
leave something human behind not just a
lump of flesh not just any other thing
but something that's light to them
behind don't don't parents will often
see something of themselves and their
children or those who don't are
sometimes disappointed they don't see
something other I can't believe that
you're my kid a lot of times they they
they see a lot of themselves in their
children and you know you watch kids
over time they often turn out quite
similar weirdly enough like I don't I
don't physically if you looked if you
put
picture of my adopted dad and then me
next to each other we don't actually
resemble each other that much he was we
had his hair was going gray when he was
18 he was very thin not particularly
around the athletic well we both wore
glasses what else it was a short guy
about 5 foot 10 I'm since 3 when I was a
teenager that my dad had died people
would say you look so much like your dad
you're like Holliman can that be I took
out his mannerisms you know eventually
you come to resemble people well that's
that's great from Plato's perspective
because that means that you actually get
to leave a little bit of yourself behind
you get to enjoy eternity that's your
bit of immortality that's what the level
of the body what about at the level of
the the soul so she talks about other
things what are what are the sort of
things that people want to leave behind
as what we call their people just
actually have a legacy
a lot of people don't start thinking
about this I think until they get older
I'm thinking about death thinking about
the meaning of their life you know they
get in their 40s or 50s suddenly they're
about something different sometimes it
coincides with a midlife crisis right
what are the kinds of things that people
want to leave behind but I mean some
people are crazy they say I just want to
destroy everything in sight or I'd like
to kill everybody who belongs to this
class she wasn't talking about that for
what what makes you memorable would be
like Steve Jobs yeah innovators and now
it's not just enough to bring something
to the world that hasn't been done
before because you know the guy who had
invented jello wrestling
I'm sure his name is down somewhere
right but we don't we don't like we
don't talk about it like Steve patents
right well there are a lot of people
like jello rust like I think I don't
really don't I'm just picking this out
of random we could pick any other thing
what did Steve Jobs do that was so
important
and he introduced something that made
people's lives better if he'd introduce
something that made people's lives
worse he would be remembered but he
would be remembered as infamous right
like
a lot of times people don't want to be
remembered when that happens like you
know who is the first person who
transmitted this disease the population
we usually don't notice knew that they
died of it but you know they don't think
they want to be known as that that the
guy who is responsible for the building
collapse Bangladesh last that semester
he'll be remembered as a terrible guy
you know and Steve Jobs was not a great
guy personally apparently but he really
was able to get something interesting
done he would be somebody who'd fit into
what do know calls those who are
pregnant to the soul why well because he
he actually ordered she talks about
families and states
he ordered a company that changed our
culture you know the fact that we walk
around with these things
rely on them for so much
what else
building sometimes
yeah they try to make a ton of money I
mean every one of these buildings that
you walk through it's got a name on it
that's somebody who gave a lot of money
to this College
maybe to build this particular building
they wanted to leave something of
themselves behind or that it was to
remember their husband their wife
parents what else have any of you ever
had a particularly not just good in the
sense of any other subject but
conscientious teacher who tried to
cultivate you as a person and your time
in middle school or high school or maybe
if you're lucky you'll have some people
like that here in college probably in
your major major what are they after
they they want the good for you
but they also want to leave behind a
legacy of what people oftentimes call
spiritual children they want to leave
behind people whose lives they improve
the Ottoman and Socrates are like that
Socrates is like that for a lot of
younger people some people want to be
remembered for great deeds you know it's
like my chilis fighting other people
leave behind poetic workers don't them
musicians want to be behind that one
song that will stand the test of time
and people will be listening loving a
hundred years from now 200 years from
now it's kind of an interesting thing to
think about how much of our music that
we have we live in a golden age of music
there's never been such great music
produced as at this time in history in
all different genres how much of that is
going to stand the test of time it will
be listened to avidly by people a
hundred years from now just as eagerly
as you listen to it today that's worth
thinking about
that's what musicians once they start
thinking about their craft that's one of
the things they aim that's part of their
legacy he talks about homer and hesiod
and I wouldn't want to have children
like they do what did they leave behind
when we're left behind
The Odyssey and the Iliad two really
great classic words that have stood the
test of time you know you may have been
like required to read them in some
classroom I had this boring crap trust
me when you get older and you reread the
stuff you're gonna love this I
understand why they they kept copying
these Scrolls out by hand
for centuries so that we can have this
Plato himself as his leaving behind
children like that so that's that's all
an interesting set of reflections on
what we wanted and loved the last thing
she talks about she calls all this stuff
up to this point
lesser mysteries what is the greater
mystery
what is the real revelation
sort of laughter then you climb up a
locker moving from one thing to the next
to the next to the next
ultimately reaching the pinnacle
Beautiful's itself which you can't see
touch smell here you can only envision
with your mind you can only capsicum
catch a glimpse of it through through
your contemplation but it's what makes
everything else beautiful everybody that
sort of trickles down everything below
well that's the very bottom our bodies
physical forms bodies are beautiful I
think they are attracted not just human
bodies but animal bodies too right
and we see them now you even even
paintings we need to go to the museum
you like Bob I don't understand what
this paintings about but I like the
colors
there's something in it that responds to
me physical things we start excuse me we
start off being in love with one body he
says and then we should move on to
another one and fall in love with that
one experience love inside and then come
to realize that all these beautiful
bodies that we loved then they had
something in common that transcends them
which is you know the sort of beautiful
beautiful form we have a type you know
once you actually this is kind of
psychedelic but looking back on it you
know over 40 years of this sort of stuff
once you figure out what your type is
you've really saved yourself a lot of
time when it comes to dating and romance
and all that sort of stuff now you can
go and find you know a beautiful body
that has set that type hopefully that
that beautiful body will be connected to
something that's more important than the
body is the beautiful soul if you don't
like the word soul because of its fee
illogical
you know implications say personality
you know we often joke about it we're
not good-looking with their two great
personality personality does matter over
time more than most because personality
is more permanent and we'll stick with
it you know if you're overweight you can
drop the weight you know if you're out
of shape you can you can go to the gym
and work out use makeup to cover up you
know there's problems with things you
can get implants good things taken out
you can do all sorts of things to the
body right not so easy to do the
personality if you're a jerk
can you get a can you get a jerk
jerkiness removal we're not you know
they try to do stuff like that or you
know programs and southbound on but it
takes a lot time we have to do a lot of
painful digging and sometimes it doesn't
take you know but falling in love with
beautiful souls that's a higher level
that's getting you closer to to what's
most real what's most valuable now
here's where it gets really interesting
what makes Souls good
he uses this term as laws and
institutions the way in which you you
live something that transcends you so
for instance being up sports team that
is an example of institution
yep being on a sports team
for instance rowing right you have to
coordinate in ways which in other sports
you don't have to so much to to a very
tight to reviewed with the guys on your
your squad right where do they call the
crew did you learn how to do that by
being a boat with wrong or did you
already have that developed at that
level before but you everybody you kind
of learn paddle everybody or it's all in
place so you're learning something
valuable that is that is actually
contributing something to your soul they
will be able to transfer it on their
areas you know you get it with a bunch
of different colleagues at work you know
wherever you're having to go you'll have
some difficult colleagues trust me and
you think well I got out of like learn
how to be in sync with them and if I can
do with these these guys on the rowing
team I think I can transfer some of
those skills that's the institution
having affected your soul having made
your soul better have you made your soul
some respects more beautiful more what
it ought to be all sorts of when when
the institutions are good when the laws
are good they make the soul they make
the personality good these good these
are not to be the law is in the sense of
like the laws of the municipality they
could be the way your family works
they could be all sorts of things along
those lines we also use the words of
practices with us what would make those
good so you know you move from loving
people's souls to be like that person is
great I like this Socrates guy I like
this play-doh guy any sort thing about
yeah I like what you know whatever it is
that could like form them I love that
even more
well Sciences or wisdoms forms of
knowledge the things you're studying in
your majors that's would actually inform
our good laws of institutions
knowledge understand that becomes
something that you become attractive and
you know you could you could become
attractive that in the way which would
be very early called monogamous right
you you are in love with sociology or
accounting or you know pick other things
like that people do fall in love with
their job and when they fall in love
with their job hopefully it's not just
they like filling in forms and that sort
of thing they actually like Indians that
are the basis and eventually if you work
through many of these you will catch a
glimpse of this
that which is beautiful in itself not
beautiful because something else has
made it so everything trickles down in
this hierarchy from the top downward but
you have to go as a human being you have
to go up this ladder you can't just jump
- well you know let's say you do this
lecturing you're like yeah beautiful
itself hell I'm gonna skip all this
intermediary nonsense you should give me
that dr. Sadler if Plato was right you
would actually have to spend some time
learning right you probably don't even
spend a lot of time learning out a lot
of bodies and then learning how to love
Souls learning how to love laws and
institutions learning how to love
knowledge for its own sake and then
seeing something beyond knowledge itself
that is even more attractive even more
desirable it's not like you can
short-circuit it there's no there's no
10-point system to get you through
quicker or anything like that
no crash course kind of an interesting
idea this is where Socrates leaves off
and that's where the suppose you'd
really want to end isn't it what happens
instead who shows up
rich you know good-looking playboy yeah
Elsa babies shows up yeah and his speech
is kind of ramble I'm not going to go
over all the like you know who's gonna
sit next to who business because we
don't have time for that but this speech
kind of rambles across three different
things one of these is this this very
confessional you know story of how I
loved but didn't succeed he tries to
seduce Socrates and not just seduce him
like you know I want to take classes
from here he wants literally to get
Socrates to sleep with them because he
thinks that if he can do that then he's
like puffs on his nice face guy he
thinks that Socrates will share his
virtue and wisdom with them that's gonna
be one of these older men these kind of
things that were you know so common with
the ancient Greeks and you know Elsa
Biden is a super good-looking rich
charming who can't eat yet turns out you
can't get Socrates and so you get this
this this long story about his painful
experience of rejection yeah it starts
up first I stuffed the Serpent's Elena
thought for sure this is gonna work out
it's almost like a you know watching one
of these date movies you know first they
tried to do this and the person just
doesn't get right
we like that you're a really great
friend Alcibiades Alcibiades want
something more then he wrestles with the
Greeks like to resume kit so if
anything's gonna work it's gonna be that
Socrates doesn't do anything that what
is with this guy invites him to dinner
first time Socrates eats dances thanks
for dinner
see you later well the second time
Alcibiades finds a way to keep them
there overnight get Socrates you know
sleeping gets under the covers with
Socrates
still nothing's happening finally you
know maybe we get this law
little little speech thing and he says
do you know what I'm meditating I think
that of all the lovers who have ever had
I've ever had you were the only one
who's worthy of me and yet you appear
too modest to speak now I feel I should
be a fool to refuse you this or any
other favor
therefore I son delay their feet all
that I have all of my friends have in
the hope that you will assist me in the
way of virtue which I desire above all
things and I should certainly have more
reason to be ashamed of what Wiseman say
if I were to refuse a favor to such as
you none of the world where mostly fools
blah-blah-blah-blah-blah and Socrates
says thanks that's really nice flattered
we'll talk about that some other time
so now Alcibiades has been turned down
yeah and she finds himself that's not
the way that it's often happens in real
life right when when these sort of
situations occur the person who's
originally trying to like it out like
aren't you attracted to me they get back
to their turn right friendship is great
expression since we want jits if we if
we wanted waiting meeting follow me and
I won't run away from you run away from
me and I don't follow you and that's
exactly what happens and that's kind of
interesting but what's more interesting
is as talked about with this guy's why
is this guy Socrates so attractive
that's worth have any views I've seen
pictures of Socrates you should go
online you know google it
they've got busts of them you know these
sort of head snatches he's ugly he is
you know
ugly as sin got this squished face you
know he looks like somebody hit him with
a shovel maybe he was short he was fat
he was balding it's sort of uh the sort
of guy who would you'd expect you know
to go out when he was about four years
old and buy a red sports car you know
because he has to compensate for all
these other things so why are all these
these young guys who have a lot going
for them why are they all attracted to
this guy Socrates well this is about the
inner and the outer or what we often
call the exit spirit and that's what's
here these are fancy words were saying
outside inside and Alcibiades says
Socrates is like these satyr statues the
satyrs are these half goat half half-man
things that generally you know like to
cause a lot of trouble in ancient Greece
and you know try to sleep with the nay
ads of the names you know that female
sent me divine beings and they're kind
of wild and really kind of ugly
you know goats are not particularly
good-looking things anyway not very good
man
so Socrates looks like one of these
statues but open him up inside what's
inside golden treasures what are the
golden treasures and Agathon speech he
talked about love and all the virtues
and there's been a lot of talk about
different virtues like courage
temperance over the course of this
dialogue Socrates according nail
societies is the guy who has these how
do we know that well he's got temperance
which has to do with regulating your
your desires and your pursuit of
pleasure because he doesn't sleep with
this this kid who's trying to seduce
everybody else oh no the town seems to
want to sleep with so imagine you know
put input in our context you know
whatever it whatever way your taste go
some supermodel the who's rich and
charming and brilliant besides they want
to hang out with you because they won't
sleep with you are you able to to say
this we probably should think this
through where you sleep with them
Socrates says let's think it through
he is temperate he's also just he
doesn't take advantage of people what
else what about courageous how do we
know that Socrates is courageous what
else does how somebody tell us
where did he get to see Socrates yeah a
couple of couple different times
Socrates is able to put up in physical
hardships and other people I'm really
bothered as a matter of fact it ticks
off the other troops that he doesn't
seem affected by then on the retreat and
you know if you had if you first of all
ancient work there back then when they
talk about the heavy armed troops these
were guys who carried these big shields
you probably seen them in a few movies
then these long Spears and then they
carried a short sword and the whole goal
was to like use that shield to keep the
other guy from doing what he wants to do
so what you wanted to ram their spear
through his belly yeah or maybe you know
cut across a hat or something I'm going
to get too close to use the spear you
get the story out of destruction yeah
very blunt start stuff I mean I would
scare that the crap out of most people
anyway I think it's you know it takes a
lot of courage to be engaged in modern
warfare but but it probably takes a bit
more to get close up and personal with
people than to shoot them from do other
yards away a little bit easier to do
that scary but not not SK so Socrates
now they're on the retreat and you're
them to retreat when you guys have lost
and there's the enemy has them you know
more of their troops coming in and
there's two ways you can retreat one is
using I'm getting the hell out of here
and everybody takes off and if you do
that they're gonna kill all because they
just come in and run you down or do you
can retreat in good order that's what
Socrates is helping them do one with
this guy who becomes another general
lockets it was actually a dialogue like
it's about courage socrates not only
saves Alcibiades life he tells the
generals I don't want the reward for
valor give it to Alcibiades
so clearly he has courage does Socrates
have wisdom
wait
his words and trans people even the out
of distance like these these flute signs
Mircea stuff the satyr
so they also buy these is it's telling
us something about side but he's doing
it the way to wrong people here it was
kind of rambling here at there how does
this end
alcibiades you know some work people
first in everybody starts drinking heavy
lot of people pass out some people say
I'm getting out of here like eczema
guess drink very much who's left up
again yeah what's that
decided socrates son is there there's
two other guys still at the table
drinking still talking about them the
guy who's marrying it says I was like
passed out and I woke up I couldn't
remember station but he understood
within the main topic was it was whether
the tragic the tragedy writer can be
also a comedy writer and who are the
tragedy and how many layers
Aristophanes and Agatha so he's
discussing their craft with them after
this this total bust out pardon that's
where it leaves off we never actually
hear any any platonic discussion of that
Jesus or like throwing that out there's
and well at another time we'll talk
about this and that's that's where it is
so you've got all these different
conceptions of love rolled into this one
dialogue and now it's time for you to
sort your thing about how to sort things
out which of these you want to think
about